restez bien c'est vous je les trouve
totalement stupide et pardonne donc ça
c'est sûr je les trouve totalement
stupide qui est deux qui part le tél
c'est une femme
we do not least one artistes mais on est
visée ou pas parce que c'est pas
nous concerne c'est nous qui ça c'est
une comédienne véronique genest bravo
leur usage
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas du tout mais je connais
très bien le personnage j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur elle et par déduction son
nom m'est venue immédiatement jury oui
elle ne peut pas vous blairer alors est
ce qu'elle est venue dans une interview
de jordan de luxe c'est pas moi je me
retourne toujours donné d'interview je
sais pas pourquoi je donne aucune le
regard des gens n'aiment pas du tout
comme ben moi j'aime pas vergès perd 2
verdez
depuis mais bon ce personnel est stupide
parce que pourquoi parce qu'il attaque
sont stupides parce que je trouve qu'il
a dit dédé
quand je l'entends je le trouve stupide
et puis on a un autre que je trouve
chantilly stupide c'est comment il
s'appelle mathieu delormeau stupide
matthieu delormeau montre aussi qu'il a
des raisonnements des fois un peu petit
peu idiot pas bon mais c'est bon c'est
mon oui c'est mon opinion il est surtout
assez manipuler j'ai des sentiments mois
qu'il a c'est manipuler ah bon annacone
mais la raison j'ai des raisonnement
stupide sur la gpa surnage homosexuels
ce qui est fou c'est qu'il doit
démocratie c'est à dire qu'elle ne sais
pas j'ai l'impression qu'il ya aucun
fond aucun argument aucun on est là à
baden un argument tu dit quelqu'un est
stupide pourquoi il est stupide là non
il lui suffit alors autant sur verdez
c'est pas pour je tape pas dessus parce
qu'il est pas là mais ça que ben berden
chipie les entendit conviction viendra
pas dans le vent en quoi sa part ça
revient ça voilà mais moi non quand même
moi parce que je suis là aujourd'hui
mais il ya un truc qui est sûr c'est que
dans tout paris il ya quand même ce truc
qui revient souvent on dit matthieu
delormeau petit malin très futés away
stupide je pense vraiment pas
des petits malins des gens du beau gosse
intéressés moi j'ai toujours entendu
petit malin très futur est très voilà
donc moi j'ai entendu connard
oui si bien en fait on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord avec toi parce
que tu as des opinions tranchées le mot
stupide l inverse de ce que tu vas tu
développes lui donne des arguments dont
elle est ridicule en disant ça et comme
suit très brillant et très intelligent
quand j'ai quitté tpm p ça fait le truc
un peu tu sais de la fiq est très jolie
on n'ose pas l'approcher et du coup
personne n'a osé m'appeler
mais résonne céder son lit pas
intelligent
j'ai très vite compris ce truc là où va
la véronique genest bas couture lieu on
lui a répondu à bien à côté de cela le
courage de dire ce qu'elle pense je suis
pas d'accord avec ce qu'elle dit mais au
moins c'est une nana sont suivis me sens
exactement battue bat toute religion -
quoi le pense quelque chose elle a pas
peur elle sait très bien que ça va
provoquer des réactions qu'elle va se
faire votre torpillé par touches qui
l'attend ce qu'elle pense qu'elle n'a
pas tort sur tout avec brio